we've been looking at the roots of unity
and one of the surprising and cool
things about the roots of unity is that
even though
they are by and large or complex numbers
the roots of unity actually give us a
lot of
insights about just the real numbers
which is one of the many reasons why
looking at complex numbers is not just
looking at some
weirdo exotic peripheral system of
numbers it's actually
a very natural extension of the real
numbers which is why
we get results like this one you can see
in part d here which has nothing to do
apparently with complex numbers but
we're going to get there via
knowledge about complex numbers so let's
have a look at this first question and
see what knowledge is going to be
relevant to it
it says let omega equal cos 2 pi 9
plus i sine 2 pi 9. that's what that cis
notation is an abbreviation for
and then show that omega to the power of
k where k is an integer
is a solution of this equation over here
on the right hand side and when you have
a look at that equation
even though it's never really used
specifically the language of roots of
unity here
this equation here tells us we're
looking at the ninth roots of unity
so as i see it there are kind of two key
questions that we need to answer to be
able to
show the result that's being required
here right first we know what omega is
that's been defined for us but what's
omega the power of k how are we going to
deal with that
and secondly what does it mean for some
complex number like omega the power of k
what does it mean for it to be a
solution of the equation
z to the nine equals one how do we go
about showing that
so uh let's begin with part a i'm going
to write this out in
long form omega equals cos 2 pi over 9
plus i sine 2 pi 9 and then what i want
to think about
is well what piece of knowledge or what
skill do i have
access to that enables me to raise a
complex number
to an integer power and hopefully your
brain is going there
um it's going to be demorphous theorem
right so i'm going to say if
this is omega then omega to the power of
k
is going to be equal to um you recall
that um this raising to a power
multiplies these two arguments here by
whatever power
we raised to so i'm going to write that
as cos
uh two k pi on nine that's probably the
most natural way to write it
plus i sine two k pi
on nine um and this doesn't come out of
thin air it comes by demodulation so i
should quote that right
so i'm going to say by demarcus theorem
so this has settled for me
what omega to the power of k is and then
i want to say
well how do i show that this is a
solution of the equation z to the 9
equals 1. well i can actually go a
little bit further here because i
actually know a lot about
what happens when you have some multiple
here
and raise it to the power 9. i'm not
just raising the power of k which is the
first use of demolition theorem
i'm going to raise that to the power of
9 because to be a solution
of an equation means substituting in
that particular value will make the
equation true it will satisfy
the equation that's what we mean when we
say something like oh what are the
solutions
of an equation like this the solutions
are
x equals negative 2 and x equals
negative 3 a factor you would arrive at
by you know
factorizing that's an x plus 2 and x
plus 3.
so it can be clearly shown by putting in
negative 2.
it doesn't matter what happens this
second factor over here this makes it 0
so 0 times anything
does indeed equal 0. so what we're
trying to show is that if i put this
into here um i've raised it to the power
of nine i should get
one well that means i've got to use a
second application of demand for serum
so what i'll say is
similarly and now i'm going to
that's very messy uh raise this thing
here to the power of nine
um i will get omega to the power of k to
the power of nine
equals um and now just like before i am
going to multiply these things by
the integer power raised by in this case
nine so what i get is very simply
cos 2 k pi plus i sine
2 k pi and what's great about this is
that
i now see i've got these trigonometric
functions here which
are periodic every 2 pi radians so
cos of 2k pi if you have a think about
what cos is doing
let's just draw a really quick and dirty
sketch over here this is what cos looks
like right
so you can see at 0 at 2 pi
it would happen at you know if i kept on
going to 4 pi and 6 pi
in other words at every integer multiple
of 2 pi
cos is equal to 1. you can see it up
there right that's the the amplitude
that you can see there
so i've got this 2k pi no matter what
value of k
is because i know k is an integer i can
say that's
one and similarly if i
get rid of this cos graph and put in its
place a sine graph
horribly messy but i can still see the
most important thing which is that at
all integer multiples of 2 pi like 0
like 2 pi like 4 pi sine is equal to
0 that's the value that it takes on so i
can say
plus i times 0 that's what happens
to this and the reason for this is
because of what i mentioned before the
fact that i have a domain restriction
on k k is an integer and that's the
reason why you get these particular
values so
since that's my reason i should quote it
i should invoke that fact so k is an
integer
that's the reason why i'm getting this
lovely simplification here
so what have i just shown i've got
this guy here equaling
just you know this is zero this is one
so
because this satisfies this is in the
form z to the power of 9 equals 1.
it's just that this is my chosen z
that's enough to say
this is a solution right so i can say
therefore omega to the power of k
is a solution that's all we needed so
that that question uh
came in two parts number one
um i had to deal with what omega the
power of k was and then i had to know
what does it mean for something to be a
solution of a given equation i need to
show that substitution okay so far
so good so there's part a done enough so
part b says
show that and then there's this long
polynomial in omega here
equals negative one how am i going to do
this well
because this is a show question right i
want to make sure my working is very
clear so what i'm going to do
is i'm going to take advantage of a
factorization that i know but i
i'm not just going to pull it out of
nowhere this is a show question so i'm
going to say
consider because this is a result which
isn't used like
super frequently it's going to be
not the difference of squares not the
difference of
cubes but the difference of ninth powers
that's what i'm going to have here
if i consider taking this over to the
left-hand side z to the power of nine
minus one um z to the power of nine is
the ninth power of z
one is also a ninth power it's the ninth
power of one
so therefore what i'm gonna do is i i
know in my mind
that actually this is going to be a
factorization but
i'm going to have to prove that this is
the fact because the question does say
show
so it's going to go like this and it's a
general form
you may recognize this from doing you
know difference of squares and
difference of cubes
is just the smaller versions of this so
this goes all the way down because they
chose for us a very high power
all of this plus one i'm just going to
consider this right and i want to see
what happens when i expand it so i'm
going to say
this equals 2. now what happens is when
i when i multiply z
by everything here this is going to
become z to the 9 z to the 8th
z to the 7 and so on my last term will
be
a z right so everything ratchets up by
one power so i'm just going to be a bit
cheeky and i'm just going to write all
of those terms and then there will be a
z to the 9 hanging out the front so this
is what happens
when i multiply a z by everything
what happens when i multiply everything
by minus one well you get all these same
terms but the
the coefficient will be negative one so
again i'm going to be a little bit
sneaky and take all these terms
and then instead of adding them what's
happening is i am
subtracting that's that's the difference
this makes so
all of these become subtracted as well
like i said
sorry that's a bit cheeky but at least
you don't have to wait for me to write
all these terms out again
so this is just me expanding the whole
thing in a very very long form
but you can see it doesn't take much
effort to sort of notice
that many many terms are going to cancel
in here right
um your z to the sevens your z to the
eighths
everything uh except for you know the z
to the nine hanging out the front
no like terms for it to collected this
uh minus 1 hanging out at the end
so these guys here will be your only
remaining terms so they
equal to everything said to the known
minus 1.
so therefore i can say they're for and
remember like if i weren't
asked to show that this was a result i
would probably just go straight to this
factorization that i saw on the top line
but i've been asked to show it so i
don't just come out of thin air
i can say therefore since whoopsie daisy
let's actually write this
since z to the 9 equals 1 that's what i
got from part
a i can say z to the 9 minus 1
that equals 0 but i just found an
alternative way to write
z to the nine minus one um i just showed
the z to the nine minus one is equal to
this factorization here right so i'm
gonna substitute this
for my z to the nine minus one
so that equals zero this is my new left
hand side
so how do i go from this to the result
i'm after well i can say
you know i'm going to get a solution for
this from z equals one but i'm also
going to get a solution from this
being equal to zero right if this is
equal to zero
then the product of this factor and this
factor will indeed be
zero so therefore i can say all right
what we're right there for
therefore this guy over here
that can equal 0. and
all i need to do to get this over to
what i want is i've got all of these
guys
here right which i can substitute in
to here um and i can say oh all right
well i can take this over and make it a
minus one
and i know that omega to the power of k
is already a solution of this equation
so
i can just choose k equals one and that
will give me omega right so let's go
ahead and do that
i'm going to say subtract 1 from both
sides there were a couple of steps i
just described there
so that equals negative 1. i'm going to
say but
omega to the power of k is a solution
oopsie does he is a solution
so if k equals 1 um then i'm i'm putting
in omega
to the power of 1 as a solution so
therefore i'm going to get as required
omega the power of eight plus or
negative power of seven plus omega power
is six
i'm going to get all of them
my omegas are bigger than my z's so i'm
all the way over here and that should
equal
as required negative 1 so i can say
done that is the result that i was asked
to prove
in part b so show that this is true
finished